pour bien des gens choisir le produit
qui se vante de contenir moins de gras
est une garantie d'acheter un aliment
qui est bon pour la santé
oui j'achète toujours les produits
faibles en gras oui il faut que je fasse
attention à ma santé
jamais vraiment trois chercheuses de
l'université de toronto risque de
dissiper les illusions de bien des
consommateurs
elles ont analysé des milliers de
produits éthiques et et sans gras faible
en gras ou teneur réduite en gras trans
après les avoir regroupé en une
quarantaine de catégories
elle conclut que plus de la moitié ne
contiennent pas moins de gras est
souvent plus de calories dans les
produits de boulangerie aussi beaucoup
dans certains yugo faut faire attention
donc quand on diminue grosch souvent
pour rajouter du goût mais on ajoute du
sucre donc en bout de ligne ce n'est pas
avantageux
l'effet pervers de ces produits allégés
c'est que les gens ont tendance à en
manger de plus grandes quantités
c'est démontré dans les études on en
consomme plus has considère donc j'en
mange plus et c'est vraiment documenté
30 à 50 pour cent fois plus que les gens
vont manger du produit lorsque cette
affiche est léger en ce grand grand
écran plusieurs groupes qui revendiquent
une meilleure réglementation sur
l'étiquetage auprès du gouvernement
fédéral évite les consommateurs à se
méfier du marketing
on aura beau vent le meilleur étiquetage
ou la meilleure information sur le côté
des bois mais c'est en avant dans le
marketing trompeur qui vient semer la
confusion ce consommateur on règle aucun
problème
la nutritionniste nathalie jobin
n'achète jamais ces produits allégés
les aliments qui ont une allégation
faible en grotte je tairai faut pas
oublier que ce sont tous des aliments
transformés pour elle la clé d'une bonne
alimentation
c'est de consommer le moins possible de
produits transformés ici anne louise
despatie radio canada montréal